in international news a global
confrontation over ukraine exploded at
the u.n security council at an emergency
session yesterday russia accused the u.s
of whipping up tensions and the russian
ambassador just walked out before a
speech from ukraine's representative
meanwhile near the ukraine border russia
continues to hold those ominous military
drills holly williams is in eastern
ukraine which has been a conflict zone
for the two sides since
2014.
president biden believes there is a
distinct possibility that russia will
invade ukraine this month sparking fiery
scenes at the united nations security
council but here in eastern ukraine in
these trenches that carve their way
through farmland
and shattered villages ukrainian
soldiers are already fighting against
russian-backed separatists they've been
at war since 2014 in a devastating
conflict that's taken more than 14
thousand lives according to the
ukrainian government
the town of divka is battle scarred and
broken with the wreckage of war lying on
its outskirts around 200 yards from the
front line
sergey lagenke works for the local
government and showed us this field
planted with a deadly crop
so it's a sign telling people this is
this is the minefield yes don't go any
further don't go and the whole area here
is a minefield yes
in 2014 separatists took control of
towns and cities in eastern ukraine and
as the country spiraled into war
the separatists backed by russia avdevka
became a flashpoint
its residents were caught in the
crossfire
many people fled homeless and hopeless
as the u.s warns of a possible russian
invasion
ukrainians seem remarkably calm perhaps
because they know they cannot control
their giant neighbour
some believe russia's president vladimir
putin wants a ukraine that answers to
him and intends to use force to get his
way it's not a new idea in avedivka war
it's every day difficult
you know when you don't have water when
you don't have electricity it's very
very bad you're already living with war
yes
russia maintains it has no plans to
invade ukraine but in this country
russian aggression isn't a possibility
it's a reality for cbs morning's holly
williams on the front line in eastern
ukraine